why why did you want to go into piracy
but what made you want to conduct piracy
local iso the iso a little way you or
other one for the oven can grow up
yeah i'm getting my devil on call myself
the other one until the work was enough
the national guard while demand work at
the moment longer in the Horn of Africa
the line between fishing and piracy has
long been blurred
the first pirates were actually
fishermen turned vigilante
they attacked foreign boats they
believed were fishing illegally in
Somali water's fine
during her room off the somali coast
where those pirates attack that vessel
when they realized that they could make
huge profits by holding these boats to
ransom piracy became big business and
Somalia became a no-go zone for
Americans and other Westerners we have
seen a dramatic increase in piracy in
this area and it is a matter of real
concern as a maritime investigator
piracy is my specialty for over six
years I've been doing hostage
negotiations and ransom drops so if the
murder video is connected to piracy it
ought to be a no-brainer for me to prove
I Carson thanks for agreeing to talk to
me
can you tell me why you're here in
prison or I don't know at all it took
was a panel gonna get them off but the
nopal identity yamaha motor page that
cannot go see out corridor and opee
gotta get back to back up their opinion
and other positions around with
different amount of the matter has a
holiday
yeah the mother nature is the heart of
this on my laptop and lower chakra his
brother and for you being a fisherman
you recognize like a boat like this will
get on I'll buy you another one got an
average of the down either
do you think this person is from Somalia
my does he look Somali model ah
call it what you want but the guys in
that prison are convicted pirates
what's interesting though is all the
deck and swear that the victims in the
water with Somali pirates I showed those
photos to actual Somali pirates and they
said no these guys do not look Smalley
and they just don't fit the bill